foreign
Francisco California and talk to Jacob
what's up Jacob
hey John thank you so much for taking my
call of course what's up man
yeah um I guess I'll get right into sir
the last few years I've been struggling
with
um porn addiction
tell me about it man yeah
so um hold on one second is that the
first time you've said that out loud
I think so yeah yeah thank you for
sharing that man
of course did that feel weird and
surreal to say that out loud
well I've read I've written it down on
the paper a lot but
um yeah that's the first time I set it
up yeah well I'm I'm grateful that you
um trusted me enough to
to say that appreciate that so tell me
tell me about the the origin story here
man
yeah uh uh I guess I'll walk you through
the like how I got to this point and how
it like the reason why I want the call
and
perfect yeah
so earlier this year I started reading a
book
um on your past change your future
and I got to about halfway
and one of the questions to ask is uh
what are a few things that you did
either growing up in the recent past the
hot tube or that violate the person that
you want
and for me this is one of those things
how did you get started
as in like
I mean if you go back and you you pull a
thread on your your personal story your
personal history when's the first time
you were exposed to this that you knew
oh I want to see that again
when I was 12. okay and it started off
as
um
just like regular pornography and then
it slowly got worse and worse throughout
throughout the years
um
I'd say it was at its worse when I was
like 15 or 16. and I'm still trying to
like get over the hums but
um it's worse I was engaging in
um video chat pornography with other
women online okay
even as a as a 15 and 16 year old
yes wow
so much for the safeguards they talk
they're so proud of
yeah there's just adults talking to
adults yeah that's tough man that is um
blowing out the hedonic sensor in your
brain man that's a lot of a lot of
Freewheel and cheap dopamine circling up
in that system and that is really really
hard to just control all delete and walk
away from so what has happened recently
that that you reached out usually people
something has happened
yeah what happened so uh recently I'm
starting out the first semester of
college
and oh so you're 18 right now
yeah this is like my second week oh wow
okay
how's the first week going
oh man it's so much fun I I really like
it um
yeah
it's going great okay so this is week
week you're into week two
what happened
well I think right now would be a good
time to really
um you know be aggressive and try and
get some work done on this and move
forward
let us be aggressive look like for you
that looks like
making progress
um putting in the hard work to end this
addiction okay
I agree with the be aggressive part of
what you said
that is counter to make progress
okay we're going to make progress on the
the cheap dopamine we're going to make
progress on channeling some of this
angst and loneliness and shame into
productive behaviors okay
but we are going to be aggressive about
the
external presenting problem as is the
way we say it in the nerd World okay
okay what does that mean that means if
you're gonna get serious about this you
have to go scorched Earth and here's why
it's everywhere
and so when you like
when somebody is struggling with alcohol
when they have deemed themselves an
alcoholic
they cannot have a beer
especially at the beginning they can't
go into a bar at the beginning they
can't go to a friend's house where
they're serving alcohol at the beginning
many of them can get there over time but
at the beginning it is scorched Earth
what does scorched earth mean for you
that might mean getting rid of your
phone
or sharing apps with your parents
that might mean getting rid of your
laptop which makes College almost
impossible
and you have to go to the school library
to type on something or you have to
borrow a laptop from the school and what
I'm saying sounds insane and people are
going to be driving listening to this
and roll their eyes
but I've sat with too many young people
in your situation dude in college in my
dean of students offices at colleges
across the country and you are haunted
aren't you
I think so yeah
fair enough Fair
absolutely fair so
do your parents have any idea that
you're struggling so much or that you've
been
engaging in what I I mean
live sex via Zoom essentially since you
were 15 years old 14 years old
well I think they they
knew at some point but I don't think
they knew just how bad it was were they
thinking like with a Playboy mindset
like a lot of parents a lot of parents
hear pornography and they think of the
Playboys that their friend's dad had
under the bed or their dad head under
the bed
they don't have a psychology for oh no
my son is talking to somebody in another
country and she will do anything he asks
her to and talk back to him the whole
time
right that is not in most parents
psychology and that you can do that from
your freaking cell phone
yeah or your laptop in your bedroom
and you're saying I'm playing Call of
Duty mom and you're literally talking to
a 24 year old woman in another country
that is an insanity and a Madness that
most parents don't understand is
happening
Fair
okay
so two words that are really important
to me when I hit when I'm sitting with
somebody who is struggling with any sort
of a form of addiction and my guess is
you've you've tried to not do this on
your own right like you've said I'm not
doing this every morning you shut the
laptop and you delete all the apps and
you slowly found your way back is that
fair
yeah that's that's definitely been the
situation on and off over the last few
years okay so the two words that always
guide my conversations with folks is
awareness and curiosity so I'll just ask
you
what are the times if you look back and
you could say oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
one of the times you have re-downloaded
the apps
anytime I've found like a loophole or
some way to access
um
the addiction
so like I'll give an example so like
last week I had
um an old Chromebook that I forgot I had
and I guess I was so desperate that I
ended up using it
um and then immediately after I I threw
it away
well I do agree with you that most
Chromebooks should end up in the trash
like we we are in alignment there
um
man
so when somebody says I'm struggling
with pornography I've got a porn
addiction
um
that's a spectrum
but
just you and me being honest you're way
over your head aren't you
I'm actually not quite sure um what that
means
that means you found your ways into some
dark areas of the world through that
through that computer haven't you
yeah
and you've seen some gnarly stuff
haven't you
yeah yeah
have you reached out to a professional
at this point
um I have not okay I need you to hear me
super clear okay you're on a trajectory
a rocket ship to jail
you are particularly on a rocket ship to
get yourself kicked out of college
okay
okay I'm telling you that because I've
investigated one step of where you are
right now at the University level on
multiple occasions
okay
yeah
am I right
um yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna trust for
you sir okay no you're on a dangerous
path as I'm telling you
and if you haven't already you will be
approached for things
that because here's what here when you
say you get desperate
it's that pressure it builds and it
builds and it builds and it builds and
you will do anything like find an old
computer and you will eventually end up
on a school laptop or your neighbor's
laptop or you will find yourself
responding to a chat like hey if you
think that was cool I got something for
you or some call girl on the computer
who says
if you thought that was awesome
click this link or call this number
because they'll up the ante and now you
are way over your head
and so what what I'm telling you right
now is and it it doesn't happen it
happens so benign and so next step that
suddenly people go oh my because I'm
here
I have a I have a computer full of child
pornography I have a computer full of
um really graphic
um like disturbing pornography if you're
not already there in either of those
situations
so here's I'm telling you step one when
we get off this call I want you to make
an appointment with a male counselor at
your College Counseling Center today
right now
got it okay I want you to go be as open
with that person as you are with me
and I want you to say the following
words
I have an addiction to pornography
but it is not just images and it's not
just movies I have for the last three or
four years been in regular contact with
live models and actors who will do what
I say on screen
you have to start there with that level
of honesty with your with your counselor
okay
okay that's step one step two you need
to see if you have a local essay I think
it's sexaholics Anonymous I don't know
the exact verbiage there in your
hometown where you happen to be I
promise you do and I promise you will
not be the only college kid in that
meeting
but the whole you have to get into a
place where you can say these things out
loud and it's important to see where
this all can head and it will also be
important to see a group of men who are
past you who are older than you wiser
than you who have
completely taken ownership back of their
life
okay
so that's two things that's two sources
of accountability here's the intentional
stuff right in front of you I want you
to write this down and I want you to put
this on your mirror I want you to put
this by your bed I want you to put this
everywhere that you're going to see
something
e y d earn your dopamine
no more hacks no more
um sideways attempts
if you want intimacy sexual intimacy
connection
I have to go on a date I have to earn my
dopamine I gotta ask somebody out and
work and risk getting um dumped if I
want to lose weight I'm not just going
to take a bunch of speed and a bunch of
um whatever pills I'm gonna go to the
gym
if I'm gonna do good on a test I'm not
going to cheat my way to that dopamine
I'm gonna study really hard
earn your dopamine is it's my buddy
Michael Easter calls it the two percent
rule it is a intentional like way of
doing life I'm gonna take the harder
path because the harder path I take the
more extraordinary the result is on the
other end of this thing
okay but this is you this is gonna be a
complete reframe what does that look
like in real life always take the stairs
always
even when you have to make two trips
avoid the elevator avoid the escalator
always tip more than you think is
appropriate always ask somebody if you
can carry their bag
and that's probably not the world you've
lived in for a long time but this is a
complete shift
okay
the second thing is is you're gonna have
to get really scorched Earth about your
products I mean your your digital access
in your house
you can't control yourself at this
moment in time you can't
so you have to put so many hurdles in
front of you
I'll go as far to say if you need to
step away from college for a semester
and have no access to a computer do that
I'll go as far to say get rid of your
your smartphone and get a flip phone
and act all cool about it like I'm just
a hip trendy cool guy with the flip
phone whatever you have to do
I just have had this conversation more
times than I can count you are over your
head you're over your head you're over
your head
and I'll give you a quote from the great
brene Brown shame eats secrets for
breakfast
shame gathers its strength and power
from secrets that's why
essay meetings and a counselor they're
going to be so crucial because I'm
saying these things out loud shame will
have no power over me anymore when you
dispel shame now you can actually get to
the issues that drive you to some of
this stuff some of that impulse Behavior
then you're going to start becoming
aware oh every time I get in a fight
with my mom or every time I feel lonely
I just start to reach for the computer
ah okay I'm going to become more aware
and more why I keep reaching for the
computer ah okay it's because I'm tired
because I haven't eaten well it's
because of Any number of things
and then when you get that shred of
awareness
as the great Dr Judge Judd Brewer says
that's when that's when Behavior change
can happen
that's it
that's going to take a minute
and what I don't want you to do is get
yourself over your head even more get
yourself arrested get continue this this
path of
hurting the women on the other end of
this stuff
and if you want to go do a deep dive
into
the women on the if especially those in
other countries on the other end of
these webcam things it's Madness now I
know that only fans is a whole other
conversation we can have but
nobody wins man
I will say this I'm really proud of you
for calling Jacob
really proud of you from Colin
I think you got to college and saw all
these incredible friends that you're
gonna make and started seeing people
that I think I want to be like this
and you knew you had this looming
terrifying secret in the closet and I'm
proud of you for opening the closet door
and saying no more
it will be a tough tough road
pornography is everywhere and every
phone every computer everywhere
so you're going to be swimming Upstream
my brother
but I promise you can do it